internet orleans they have a program
called Mars one actually google it they
already have thousands of people
volunteer to go to Mars the way they are
going to pay for this is that as a
reality show they are going to be
filming everything everybody welcome to
space and reason whichever you're here
for I do want to apologize the title of
the talk I feel like may have slightly
implied that you can buy a ticket to
space here now so if you were here for
that this is not a timeshare
presentation I'm very very sorry instead
what we're going to do is just hopefully
give you a sense for people who are kind
of new to the area give you a sense of
what the landscape looks like in terms
of the very exciting private space
industry that is that is growing right
now and for those who who know a lot we
will probably be reminding you of some
bad news you already you already weep
over and and just kind of putting it in
a in a larger context so I'm just going
to be a dual hat-wearing panelist and
moderator my name is Catherine manga
award i'm the managing editor of Reason
magazine where I cover space as well as
food and education I am joined by
charles Murray who is a fellow at the
American Enterprise Institute and who
wrote a book about the Apollo program in
1989 which remains a favorite among
space buffs to this day I also joined by
Jose Cordero who is an energy expert a
futurist and a singularity University
faculty member an errand day of the
Atlas society who will be filling us in
on the current state of the space
industry so I just want to kind of start
with a line that wouldn't work in most
venues I think which is that it's really
really great news for the future of
human space flight that the US
government is completely out of money
it must audience no but NASA and their
defunding it and you know what can we do
and I think here you guys know what I
mean which is that the total panic
induced by austerity has caused at least
some degree of pullback and cuts in
government spending which which have
been very very good for the current the
current environment so you know first
I'll say in the great scheme of things
NASA is pretty cheap and that's
something that most Americans don't know
if you pull people they think that NASA
takes about twenty percent of the US
budget these are the same people also
think like four and eight is like eighty
percent I know this is not a highly
educated pool but um but in fact NASA is
less than one percent um so we're not
talking about huge amounts of cash in
times when huge amounts of cash do go
kind of gushing out of Washington
without anyone taking any notice at the
same time we don't get very much mutt
for that money right now the house space
subcommittee just passed out a their
recommendations for procreation xin the
next year it's about sixteen billion
dollars we don't have a shuttle program
anymore the shuttle program shut down so
even the relatively kind of sad
dwindling end of you know government
sponsored us space flight in which we
were just kind of ferrying ant farms and
schoolchildren's projects back and forth
to the international space station is
now over and we've been paying the
Russians about 70 million dollars a pop
to take our people and stuff back and
forth to the International Space Station
and it's not an exciting moment there
are some tight spots the rover's people
are very excited about those deep space
projects continue a pace but luckily
there's this very exciting private space
industry that's bringing up right now
we're going to hear about the individual
players a little bit more later but the
point that I want to make is that
that whole sector that whole industry is
made possible by a couple of things one
a kind of a combination of benign
neglect on the part of regulators and a
few just really really rich dudes just
so British and these are these are guys
who made just tremendous amounts of
money and then they woke up all around
the world one day and said how is it
that I have billions or hundreds of
millions of dollars and I cannot buy a
ticket to space this is not the deal
this is no what I thought was gonna
happen when I was 10 so um a bunch of
these guys said well okay I guess I'm
just gonna have to make my own way to
space I would say there's a sort of
another category of people that
absolutely deserve credit and these are
the not so rich nerds who also woke up
with the same why can't i buy a ticket
to space range and have been doing their
part as well so um you know this is this
is definitely the benefits of living in
a society where a few people can
accumulate in vast amounts of money and
then do whatever they want with it what
that's worth in terms of the regulatory
situation I would just say that the most
important thing for the US private
spaceflight industry so far has been the
fact that right now we treat future
astronauts future customers of these
private space companies not the same way
that we treat airline passengers but
instead the way that we treat scuba
divers or bungee jumpers we treat them
as people who know that they're taking
risks and are taking on those risks
advisedly and the FAA has had an eight
year moratorium which it then extended a
couple years ago which instead of
regulating the private space industry
the way we regulate commercial airliners
just say listen try not to kill anyone
on the ground while you're flying over
and that is I think that's something
that's easy to take for granted you
might think well any early phase
industry
be allowed to bring people in who are
willing to take risks in order to take
the necessary risks to make developments
that is not in fact how the world works
as you've heard in many other talks in
many other panels these last couple of
days the other real asset to the to
private space industry right now is
Barack Obama and this may be one of the
very few places at this conference where
you hear people saying nice things about
Barack Obama but um but it's true that
he has sometimes in defiance of
congressional Republicans and certainly
I'm in a way that set him apart from his
predecessor encouraged NASA to contract
out for services where they can to
private companies this takes the form of
a few hundred million for the Commercial
Crew program which looks to get stuff
and people back and forth to the
international space station by paying
other companies and that has been a huge
success and there are still some
barriers which I'm just going to go over
quickly and then we'll move to more good
news I hope which is uh we right now
treat space ideas ideas about space and
also space technology as weapons in
terms of the way that we regulate the
international trade in those things so
the international trade and arms
regulations treat all satellites as
munitions that means that it's very very
hard for us to cooperate with scientists
and companies and you know even just
money in other countries to build a true
international industry instead the US
has to duplicate the efforts of other
countries at home we miss out on cheap
launch costs that are being offered in
other countries it's also very very hard
to hire talented foreign rocket
scientists and you know I think we can
all debate about whether that the levels
of immigration should be higher or lower
and I think shikha donvale will be doing
that in this room at two-thirty today to
put a little plug in but I rocket
scientists are scarce and really really
good ones are scarce around it
it shouldn't be so hard to bring the
good guys to work here we also have the
Iran North Korea Syria non-proliferation
act which has to be waived every single
time we buy a flight from the Russians
because we're not supposed to be doing
business with people who do business
with those countries and the other thing
is a little more abstruse and it
generally gets kind of a funny look from
people who are not already a bit
libertarian but the sort of last point
is private property in space right and
it sounds goofy when you say well people
need to be able to own pieces of the
moon people need to be able to buy
asteroids and it was like okay sure
write your science fiction novels but um
but that actually is a huge component of
encouraging innovation encouraging
entrepreneurship getting people to
invest the money to get to the moon to
get to those to get to those asteroids
and and exploit them and and make them
accessible to the rest of us and the
final point I would make and then and
then we'll all hand it over is just
we're right now at a moment where it's a
little bit unclear whether big business
or even small business is going to
revolutionize the way we do space
weather big government will manage to
capture those companies so right now
SpaceX is one of the most exciting
companies out there they're not wholly
dependent on NASA so they are not like
locking or Boeing they're not like their
predecessors but they do have they do
have I think about 900 million in
contracts with NASA right now NASA is
their biggest customer it's not their
only customer Virgin Galactic also has
contracts with NASA so do NASA safety
standards which are far too high and
have resulted in the fact that a single
shuttle launch cost somewhere between
half a billion and a billion dollars by
the time we got to end of the program
compared to a you know a few a few tens
of millions ideally will NASA safety
standards wind up bringing down private
industry or well the private that sort
of competition and innovation in the
private sector drag the US government
kicking and screaming into a sort of
more exciting and more efficient space
future and
meantime of course we'll all be buying
our tickets on Virgin Galactic any
minute now 18 months from now as they
have been saying for the last several
years so we'll see how that happened
yeah oh it's always 18 months and then
with that long enough here thank you
good morning my name is Aaron day i'm
the CEO of the Atlas society and if
you're not familiar with our
organization we promote the philosophy
of reason individualism achievement and
freedom as defined by I'm Rand but we
build on this philosophy from an open
perspective and then look at as a
growing body of knowledge I I may be the
least expert on this panel so i will say
that my my expertise my credentials in
the space area are somewhat limited i
did win a nasa award for a high school
computer simulation project on the Big
Bang when I was in the ninth grade which
but that was my initial foray but have
always long been a fan of space travel
and privatization in general obviously
being an Objectivist we have been
fortunate the outfit only for the last
two years to have Steve Davis who as a
chief engineer at SpaceX present on the
topic and actually give us an update so
I have some interesting data just from a
week and a half ago which is fascinating
when you look at their grasshopper
program and some of the things that
they're doing with respect to reusable
rockets but before I go into i'm going
to give an overview of some of the
specific projects that are going on
right now but before i do that there are
a couple of really fascinating ted talks
that you might want to take a look at
where one with burt rutan and another
with Elon Musk and burt rutan is a very
colorful character if you if you don't
know he's got the sideburns we're going
to go back to the moon and move 50 years
later and we're going to do it very
specifically planned to not learn
anything new I'm really troubled by that
you gave a really interesting overview
of the history of commercial what
commercial jet lines that inhabit even
military airlines have developed and
essentially we've seen no progress since
the 1950s and in the sr-71 project was
abandoned the Concorde was abandoned
we're not actually seeing any material
improvements since the 1950s which is
truly a tragedy and the other one of the
other points that he makes is that a lot
of innovation is driven by billionaire
entrepreneurs or people that are just
have an interest in a passion for a
particular topic or idea you know when
when he bought his first Apple Computer
in 1978 he bought it so that you know he
could tell his neighbors hey I've got an
apple you don't and come over and let's
play Frogger I mean I was essentially
what the application of of the
technology was at that point but then
obviously we found other uses for the
computer from that point moving forward
space travel at this point a lot of the
projects and efforts have been focused
on suborbital flights and one of the
reasons for that is if you look at
NASA's safety record four percent of the
people to get launched into space dye
which is not a very good safety record
if you're actually pursuing something
from a commercial perspective and so I
think that he has a lot of interesting
points on on this you on must is is a
fascinating character in the fact that
he's actually running Tesla Solar City
and SpaceX all at the same time which is
a truly amazing accomplishment and I
want to give it some of the statistics
about just how effective the
privatization efforts have been from a
cost and performance perspective NASA
had spent a hundred and ninety six
billion dollars over the history of the
space shuttle program so the average
space shuttle launch costs 1.5 billion
dollars now as a result of the SpaceX
reusable rockets they can actually send
a full cargo mission to the
international space station for 133
million dollars so that is a
significant savings mean obviously that
we're talking about you know a couple of
orders of magnitude here in terms of
efficiency and productivity the other
thing is as I mentioned you know nASA
has spent even though it isn't twenty
percent of GDP 196 billion dollars is
still quite a bit of money over a long
period of time SpaceX has accomplished
what they've accomplished between 2002
and 2010 they they've done all of their
work with under 800 million dollars of
invested capital so it is remarkable
what the free markets can do it's
remarkable what private industry can do
when it comes to trying to solve some of
these complex problems and with their
reusable rockets they're trying to get
to the point where you'll be able to see
it'll cost on average about sixteen
dollars per pound to get something into
space which is fascinating that's
actually less expensive and a cost to
use the united states postal service to
send the package overnight so i think
these are the kinds of performance
savings that we can see in the future
and one of the things that i love what
looking at all of the various
entrepreneurs involved in this
privatization movement we have you on
musk we have Jeff Bezos who has a
project called Blue Origin which he's
also which has the goal to help enable
anybody to go into space we have Richard
Branson Virgin Galactic but you know all
these people really sets have a common
approach which I would say is an
Objectivist approach that was summarized
when Elon Musk was questioned well how
can you do all of these things how can
you run all these companies and
accomplish all these great things and he
says well first I start by having a
background in physics and when I look at
a problem I look at solving it from the
standpoint of first principles and so
rather than just reason by analogy which
is often what we do from day to day we
see something we you know copy it and
make tweaks he says we'll wait what is
the fundamental problem that we're
trying to solve here and how do we
down to its component parts and then he
really focuses on collecting negative
feedback asking for negative feedback so
that he can make continuous improvements
and really focusing on the truth and
working on information working on
actually taking information using reason
to solve problems and I think that's a
common thread and a common approach that
you see with many of the people in the
privatization movement the other thing
is it turns out that this whole idea of
private investors investing spaces is
not new already I don't know if you've
heard of james lick but james lick may
be the one of the largest benefactors of
a bit i strive as maybe astronomy more
broadly he made his money during the
gold rush selling real estate and 150
years ago he spent seven hundred
thousand dollars to build the Lick
Observatory which in today's dollars is
about 1.2 billion dollars with that I'll
just touch on some of the other programs
there is Jeff Bezos program there's
orbital sciences which is really a
competitor in some respects to SpaceX
with the idea being to build reusable
rockets and and of course Virgin
Galactic which is Richard Branson's
project over 400 people have now paid
well the total cost is two hundred
thousand dollars you have to put a
twenty-thousand-dollar deposit and at
some point in the very near future here
I don't know this year next year 2015
you'll be able to go on a two-hour
flight and experience six hours of TV
six minutes of weightlessness so pretty
exciting but your checkbooks out you get
ready to go on that one but that is an
interesting development and then we have
planetary resources which Peter
Diamandis and others are involved in and
has a number of billionaires including
Larry Page Eric Schmidt James Cameron
Ross Perot behind it the idea there is
to start working on mining asteroids and
figuring out how to monetize some of the
space travel efforts and so where that
said Jose I'll turn it over to you
we're actually there will be a short
interlude before that where where I for
I am nostalgic because I i am not an
expert on what's going on now I'm here
because my wife and I wrote a book
called Apollo back in nineteen eighty
nine which was the story of how we got
to the moon not focusing on the
astronauts but focusing on the people in
the ground and and so I just want to
take a few minutes to remind those of us
in this room who can remember the first
moon landing what an incredible thing
was accomplished by a government
bureaucracy that succeeded before it had
time to become a bureaucracy imagine
that a year after nine eleven all of
NASA had been completely destroyed and
removed we were starting from scratch
with no facilities no nothing and in
November of 2002 we got 45 people who
were scientists and space engineers and
told them to go to the moon from scratch
and we landed on the moon today 2002
wasn't that long ago starting from
scratch getting to the moon today in 11
less than 11 years 10 and a half years
is incredible and that's what we did the
space task group started in November
fifth nineteen fifty eight we landed on
the moon moon and July of 1969 and the
people who did that we're working for
government and they were getting
government salaries and they behaved
like the most audacious entrepreneurs
you have ever seen that in all sorts of
decisions that were taken in all sorts
of ways I just want to give two examples
to illustrate what space exploration and
can be like again what is a very simple
one of the head of the man's face of the
Apollo space flight program was George
Lowe at the time we landed on the moon
he was an Austrian by birth a very
cultivated
lectual a very big extraordinarily
effective leader job o'buck had a high
school education he was son of Polish
immigrants and he was the chief mechanic
for the Apollo spacecraft at the Cape
every before every launch the head of
the entire Apollo program would go down
and have sandwiches with Joe mobic
because they knew each other from the
old days it was space uh Lois Center in
Cleveland and George Lowe would say Joe
tell me what they hadn't told me about
this piece craft that was the kind of
communication across lines that took
place all the time during the during the
years of Apollo people did no attention
to organization charts they they talked
to the people they needed to talk to and
they didn't care what the color of the
rugged and the floor was as they often
said the other story happened during the
launch of Apollo 12 Apollo 12 the one
after of the first Atlantic was hit by
lightning the Saturn five was hit by
lightning twice as it went to orbit in
the course of this every alarm light in
the whole cockpit lit up they lost their
guidance system completely it was
knocked off line so there they are in
orbit and over the course of a next
couple of hours the flight control team
at used emissions control created from
scratch kind of a checklist of how do
you decide whether the spacecraft is
functional after being hit by lightning
twice this was not something they had
simulate them my wife and I am doing the
research for the book wanted to find out
all the the drama of what was going on
as as the higher-ups in NASA decided
well do we okay this this with this
spacecraft to go into translunar
injection and head toward the moon after
it's been hit by lightning and after a
lot of effort we discovered there was no
such meeting of NASA's senior official
there were a bunch of 25 27 year old
guys in Mission Control the flight
controllers headed by a 32 33 year-old
flight directors they did all the checks
they decided the spacecraft is good oh
and said so they basically turned around
to the big guys sitting in the back row
who never actually did anything they
were called Hummers because when
something happened and that they were
told that deal hmm and that's all they
but give the hummers credit the Hummer
said you guys are the people who know
you go ahead so these people whose lives
would have whose professional lives were
on the line because if that had gone
wrong it would have been the hummers it
would have been the big NASA guys who
had been in front of congressional
committees being pilloried and they were
saying to their 30 25 year old guys you
make the suit go ahead I was getting
that story from gene Kranz gene Kranz is
the one in Apollo 13 the movie with the
crew coach was the hero and I was
interviewing about this and he was
pooh-poohing the idea that this was such
a big deal come on it was science they
checked out the spacecraft it was good
to go no big deal and I said to a gene
this was back in nineteen eighty six
when I was interviewing and crafts for
challenger I said gene supposed today
you had the shuttle hit by lightning
twice going to orbit do you really think
that we would do anything like say oh
that's okay go ahead and go to the moon
circumstances and gene who was very
loyal to master sort of leaned back in
his chair and glared at me for a second
and he had a very first a glare and any
person black because he knew they would
never ever
so the people who are doing the new
space private space efforts you would be
well advised to go back and talk to the
remaining guys from the Apollo era
because you want balls to use a very
straightforward word you want
willingness to take risks to put your
reputation on the line those guys had
the right stuff okay after these three
fantastic presentations let me also give
you our personal view on what is
happening in the space and as you might
notice by my accident an original inner
from here I grew up in Venezuela which
has a communist totalitarian regime
under 4 i'm not in Venezuela too often
but having a working on space issues
throughout my life I am a mechanical
engineer from MIT and my face is my
master's thesis was about the dynamic
modeling of the International Space
Station so I have been following these
for a long time and now I teach at a
singularity University which was founded
by NASA and Google in 2009 and we are
physically located in NASA Ames for
those of you who know the Silicon Valley
area but what is interesting since we
are talking about NASA that's how so
because it is bankrupt even though it
hasn't it doesn't really have a big
budget it's only 19 billion dollars 19
million dollars really is not that much
in your think of it also however that is
more than all the other is based
agencies of the world combined so this
phase body of humanity is very tiny the
European Space Agency has only about
five billion dollars Jackson which is
the japanese space agency on
about three billion dollars the numbers
about the China program and the Russian
program are not so easy to know but but
during the order of maybe also three to
four billion dollars on buying so really
it doesn't go beyond 14 billion dollars
that they hold a government investment
in a given space issues but now
unfortunately we also have competition
not only among private sector but also
our government they Chinese they have a
plan to land on the moon next year and
actually every excited because the
Russians never did it as you know they
abandoned basically going into the
monitor the u.s. I did it first but now
China has that plan and they are very
happy and very proud to be the second
nation on the planet that sends a
spacecraft and lands on the moon the
first obviously will be unmanned mission
for they plan to send chinese astronauts
also India because India is always
competed with China India has the
program as well but the the air talking
about 5 to 10 years and Japan as well so
i went to give you the international
perspective because the space program
and the spacing trick is not only the
USA and so china is very serious russia
has been more or less serious for a long
time and then india is competing against
China and they are doing this I'm Japan
also for different reasons Japan is a
country that has no resources a very
small country and so they are interested
for example to to do some work on a
space-based solar power and also for my
name's of asteroids so which is one of
the new areas in space industry
planetary resources which is a company
founded by one of my bosses at
singularity University Peter Diamandis
with the help of many millionaires as I
was saying you know the Google
are there erica schmidt Larry Page James
Cameron avatar he wants to make a new
avatar in space and then the Prospero of
junior and as so many other billionaires
so so this is coming because each tiny
asteroid of maybe just a motor meters in
diameter it's probably worth over one
trillion dollars of resources so this is
babe manya 1 trillion dollars not
1,000,000,000 1,000,000,000,000 dollars
but anyway you know that the space
industry actually it is very difficult
there is a a bad joke in the industry
that the easiest way to become a
millionaire into space industry is to be
first up billionaire then use the money
and then you become a million so so it
is a tough industry the number that
arrow game is also interesting that NASA
doesn't have a good safety record four
percent people dying but actually that's
fantastic compared to the Soviets you
know they're Russians were really really
a disaster so that is why now that there
is no shuttle program how can America
rely on the Russians to set people to
the International Space Station I think
this is the total irony you know that
now the Americans are relying on the
Russians for this what an interesting
world we're living in but i think that
the USA is doing a good thing not
talking about the moon or not much about
the morn because now the big challenge
is going to Mars and again private
industry is fantastic even lost from the
space X has said that he wants to go to
Mars he wants to live in Mars he wants
to die on Mars but he he made an
interesting comment I want to lie on
Mars but not on London
so he does want to go and also he's very
worried by the way Elon Musk is
originally South African he is very
worried that we might destroy this
little planet called Earth and that is
why it is so important for Humanity to
move out of this planet and they give
the space colonization I statue in
Hawkins that you probably also know that
36 assists in from Great Britain you
know with Lou Gehrig's disease also he
says that you know we could destroy our
civilization very easily in 10 20 years
so we have to to begin colonizing space
so I think going to Mars is incredible
there right now for projects to go to
Mars in the next 10 years this is
incredible and it has happened all in
one year in the Netherlands we have a
program called Mars one actually google
it they already have thousands of people
volunteer to go to Mars the way they are
going to pay for this is that as a
reality show they are going to be
filming everything so they hope to raise
billions of dollars they have also a
couple of Nobel Prize winner supporting
this initiative based in Holland and the
idea is that by 2023 so in 10 years the
first crew of four people will go to
Mars again this is when I went one way
ticket but it would be very person so
anyway that is the first one first one
then a famous astronaut Buzz Aldrin he
has said that the USA has to launch an
initiative in 2019 to celebrate the 50th
anniversary of the landing on the moon
the new Mars program of the USA I think
he's working very hard on this hopefully
this will be a joint effort NASA private
industry it would be actually better
only private industry but anyway so this
should be announced in the
following that years there is another a
billionaire demonstrator was one of the
first private astronauts he's a
financial guy actually he's the founder
of wiltshire phones and they wish our
index so he paid twenty dollars to the
Russians to go yeah I had yet twenty
million dollars i tend to go to the
International Space Station right and
now he has said that by 2018 we have to
send someone to Mars you know going to
Mars is not that simple because
depending on the time of the year
because they orbit of the earth and mars
are totally different they are not
related there are good times to go to
Mars and bad times to go to Mars in the
year two thousand eight eight we will
have a fantastic time you know between
10 to 11 months which is the shortest
possible time with the current
technology to arrive on Mars with the
our technology longest period would be
up to three years so there is a window
of opportunity 2018 to reach Mars on
less than 11 months and so this guy
Dennis Tito he's not going himself
probably the International Space Station
and he feels he's too old but he's
looking for a couple an American couple
preferably nine and a woman that they
get along because they have to be
together for three years in a very very
tiny space this mission actually is a
flyby Mars they are going to come back
to earth so that is another interesting
approach there is another group of
astronauts that is also a announcing
that they are planning to raise maybe
between 10 and 20 billion dollars also
to to begin the colonization of
and so you see there are many many
different things have been in the last
few months I'm talking about virgin
galactic which i think is interesting
richard branson announced last month
that he's going to do the maiden flight
on Christmas Day this year he said that
mom December 25th he would be the first
person fly with a virgin galactic so
this is called me and I think this is
very excited this is very good I love a
space as you can see my type space free
is it fascinating because in the next
few years we might even discover life
maybe not intelligent but we might
discover bacterial life in another
planet maybe there were sleeping on Mars
so so we're living in a fascinating time
and space travel is important again to
go beyond our tiny planet remember that
humans we evolved in Africa we are all
Africans and then from Africa some
humans decided to go to the Middle East
to Europe and then you know 500 years
ago the Europeans it came from the old
world to the new world to American so on
and so forth so our next step is the
colonization of space and Mars is the
right place to begin so I am pretty sure
some of you will go to Mars hopefully so
i'm planning to go but just like a
little mouse I I I don't want to lie on
land in their ass thank you